second talk
today has a title that has evolved since
last time I
looked okay but it has logic and
algebras and we
are very excited to hear what this has
to do with cloud computing which we are
all subjected to in our daily
lives um thank you so um this will be a
bit unusual both Joe and Connor will
will talk and I let them take care of
the logistics of that again remember
that for for questions that might be
more appropriate for a longer discussion
we will have that discussion right after
their
talk okay thanks so this is work that uh
obviously we're doing here at Berkeley
and um I'm also funded by Sutter Hill
Ventures so it's kind of cool we've got
venture capitalist funding basic
research I have promised them that there
is no applicable uh I'm not really sure
what this could turn into as a company
but they're cool and they've given us uh
developers to work on the project which
has just been great and they're funding
me as well so thanks to them and to
Berkeley um there's this story people
like to tell in Computing this is my
standard opening slides um uh operating
systems people really like this story
because it's sort of the Thompson and
Richie touring award story for every
platform that comes out there's a
programming environment that's that's
somehow suited to that platform that
emerges and as a result people write
things you never would have expected on
that platform and it succeeds so the
pdp1 with Unix and C is the canonical
example of this but one can argue that
in every generation of new kind of
computing platforms programming
environments have Arisen um to allow
people to build an app for that right um
and so nobody expected all the apps we
have on our phones it's wonderful
developers were uh free to write all
sorts of things strangely there's a
platform that's as old as the iPhone
called the cloud all right so AWS is
approximately the same age as the iPhone
but it doesn't have a canonical
programming model and I there's many
reasons why that might be um partly
because it's a really hard programming
environment yes so it has to deal with
all the problems of parallel Computing
um as well as things like distributed
consistency what happens when you have
uh partial failures in your system but
it keeps running so componentry is is
down but the system's still running um
and then in the modern Cloud we want
things to Auto scale so you allocate
more machines and then you free up some
machines but the program's still running
right so the platform is changing
underneath you as you're executing yeah
so this is all hard and programmers
right now are trying to this essentially
in Java right that's sort of the stateof
the- art um and the Annoying Thing is
these compilers for these languages
don't answer any of these questions that
are hard so I think honestly this is
like this hole in computer science that
nobody's filled and it seems like one of
our grand challenges from my perspective
so I've been working on it for a long
time um and I think there's still a lot
of work to do um I take inspiration of
course from this gentleman as maybe we
all do um what was cool about Ted Cod
was he said look you should write things
in a formal language you should have
formal specific ifications and then
there should be Machinery that automates
the implementation and if we do we do
that then the implementation can change
while the specification Remains the Same
this is very nice for things like
databases right so the thing is that you
know Cod was trapped in this database uh
prison for all these years and I think
there's a much broader applicability of
the design principle so you know we
worked on things in our community like
declarative networking so we brought Cod
out of the database and into the network
um so I've done some work on that um
many of us I think in this room have
done something around declarative data
science and machine learning this is a
growing area right um in the program
analysis Community the use of
declarative languages has been uh pretty
powerful so that's really cool and then
of course the hot thing which is why
we're all here is that we're g to start
to try to look at this stuff through the
lenses of algebras instead of logic or
in addition to logic which is pretty
neat and we're GNA you know we've heard
or are hearing about a variety of
different algebras that people are
playing with in this domain so um what
I'm interested in is taking Cod into the
cloud yeah and here's sort of the
analogy the way to think about it the
relational database was invented to hide
how data is laid out and how queries are
executed right and all that should be
decided sort of lazily based on the
current environment well the cloud is
just a
generalization was invented to hide all
your Computing resources and how they're
laid out so not just your your blocks on
your disk but really everything and uh
it's for general purpose computations so
the cloud in a lot of ways is the
abstraction this physical layer
abstraction the the physics of the
deployment of your code is going to
change but you want your spec to remain
the same that's how you'd really like to
program in an environment that is this
heterogeneous and elastic so I believe
that it's extremely natural for
techniques that we've been working on in
our community to try to be applied to
cloud computing and we have a project in
my group called hydro which you can read
more about um which I will tell you a
bit about
today okay so what are my goals well I
kind of want to build something like lvm
for the cloud so llvm as you may know is
a very successful successful sort of
language stack it supports many
languages including C++ and rust and
Swift um and others um it has an
internal language called its internal
representation and then it compiles down
to a variety of machine code for
different platforms so it's been
extremely successful but it doesn't
answer any distributed questions so if
you're writing a distributed program you
might ask a question like is my program
consistent in some sense or if I talk to
different machines in the network will
give me different answers and be
confused right that's a question that
distributed programmers need to deal
with here's another one my state no
longer fits on one computer how do I
partition it across multiple computers
while getting the same answer out of my
program right I want you you compiler
should figure that out for me um what
failures can my system tolerate and how
many of them before it stops working the
way that the spec declares it should um
what data is going where around the
world and who can see it right these are
all questions distributed systems always
have to answer
and then you know I have different
objective functions so I'd like to
optimize some days for maybe my dollar
spend in the cloud but I don't care
about latency or maybe vice versa um
maybe I care about particular latency uh
distributions so I want the 99th
percentile of my workload to achieve a
certain latency versus the 95th or what
have you these will all lead to
different um decisions about resource
allocation and program structure um and
so on right and if you ask these
questions of llvm you know that's the
answer you right it just it doesn't deal
with any of these issues and that's kind
of where we'd like to come in uh We've
written a uh Vision paper a couple years
ago that I can point you to um and I
won't go through all of it today um but
the idea is to use database techniques
and ideas to optimize Inc concert with
LM so lovm sort of responsible for the
single node but database techniques
perhaps responsible for the messaging
the data movement that happens in a
distributed program so here's how we
envision the hydro stack many
programming languages up top um some
techniques to translate them into an
internal representation we've got a
little bit of initial work here and then
the internal representation should be
some formal spec that is global in some
sense so it doesn't worry yet about how
many machines I have or what the
machines can do it's just a uh a
formalized specification of what you
wrote in a perhaps imperative language
okay so it's kind of machine oblivious
maybe it's a logic maybe it's an algebra
um things that are in red are work in
progress things that are in green of
work at this point in our in our in our
efforts um and then from there we want
to build a compiler and we're working
with Maxon using EGS for that compiler
um to translate down into a per node
physical algebra so every machine would
run its own little program those
programs communicate with each other
very much like a parallel query plan is
a bunch of individual query plans
running on individual machines talking
to each other over a network okay so um
this is a sort of perod physical algebra
because it's actually doing stuff we've
implemented this and R it's very fast
and I'll show you uh some of this today
so that's kind of what we envision as as
how this is all going to work at the
bottom there's something that's
deploying this on machines and deciding
how many machines and how few over
time okay so some of the topics I want
to talk about today we're going to focus
on this piece of the stack things in red
are work in progress uh very much more
questions than answers um for sure so
how do we take code and automatically
replicate it along with its Associated
state or data while ensuring that the
program continues to produce the same
outcomes as it would have on a single
machine so I'm particularly interested
in doing this in cases where the
replication comes for free and the
individual machines don't have to
coordinate with each other in a
technical sense I'll talk about but um
we'd like to avoid replication when we
can we call that free replication and
this is the domain of the calm theorem
which you may have heard of and I will
review um unfortunately the calm theorem
was done in a very particular um
framework for the proofs it's uh not at
all clear how it applies outside that
framework and so what we'd really like
is a more algebraic notion of a c
theorem which is something that Connor
is working on and after the talk if
you're interested um come find Connor
and or me to talk about that another
topic that Connor is going to talk about
today is termination detection and again
ideally termination detection where I
can decide it locally for free without
asking anyone else right so how do I
know in a streaming program that it's
done when there's other agents in the
world um so we're going to talk about
how to do that with threshold morphisms
but um Connor's got ideas about more
General Notions of equivalence classes
that may allow termination in more
settings so he'll give you a flavor of
this work in
progress the third piece we may or may
not have time for today but my student
David Shu has been working on this how
do you take a program and partition the
state of the program across machines if
the state doesn't fit on one machine so
you really need to partition the code
and the data this is very much like
traditional shared nothing parallel
databases if you like um but we want to
do this to full and rather complex data
log programs and so we've got an
implementation of paxos which is quite a
number of lines of datal log um where
David's able to do some of this
automatic partitioning um functional
dependencies have a role to play here
and it would be nice to integrate those
into an algebraic frame as
well uh and of course all this has to go
fast and ideally as fast as handwritten
C++ I'm really previous iterations of my
work we settled for interpreters and
just showing things were possible now
we'd like to convince the systems people
that things will be as fast as they want
them to be all right so um is this
business um just p in the sky um let's
see all right so we're building on an
obsession of some 10 to 12 years that
I've had now on my third group of grad
students working in this area so the
initial batch of grad students was doing
formalisms um so we have this very nice
logic called deadalus which is a subset
of datal log neeg actually um that
allows you to talk about time and space
in a particular way and it's got a nice
model Theory
um and so that works all there and we
can use that as a basis for you know our
semantics to start which is nice um and
then there was this lovely work that Tom
amalo did at hasselt on the calm theorem
which was a conjecture I had and and he
and colleagues went ahead and proved um
that talks about how if things are
monotone in some certain sense um then
you can do this free this free
replication so you don't need to do
coordination to get replica consistency
so I will talk about the colum theorem
today to give a review and then we
actually built out a language it was
slow it was interpreted it was written
in Ruby um but it integrated lates into
a data log like language um and we were
able to show that you can get stratified
negation and aggregation you can get
morphisms on your lates to allow you to
do semi- naive evaluation even with the
latices so it's really actually rather a
nice mixture of algebra and logic none
of this was formally proved but it was I
think one of the earlier systems to
observe that you could build this so
that was pretty cool and that's Neil
Conway's thesis work so we have this as
a basis this kind of Ground Zero for my
my team and then what happened is I had
a batch of students that didn't want to
do languages or Theory so they just
built stuff in the spirit of these ideas
and I'm not going to go through all this
but you know it's things like functions
as a service and uh protocols and
testing and provenance and it's it's uh
cool stuff what I do want to focus on is
one of those projects which was a key
value store Key Value store is just like
a hash table okay um it's a database
where you look things up by key and you
get a value so you can think of it as a
distributed hash table
um these are like the Petri dishes of
distributed systems you're basically
saying I have a memory it's distributed
across many computers it may be
replicated it may be partitioned but
that's what I have it's just a registers
with values keys with values yeah uh so
there's no algorithms per se it's all
just kind of like focusing on these
semantic issues about replication and
partitioning but the the idea that was
behind the Anna key value store that we
built was everything's a semilattice and
because everything's a semilattice and
therefore associative commutative and
item poent messages in the network can
be replicated they can be interleaved
they can be reordered and everything
will be fine right so if you design with
semilattices from the bottom up you can
build a system that does no coordination
so it's fully monotonic which means
everything can be replicated as much or
as little as you like across the globe
between discs and memory you can
replicate lots of ways you can do
updates anywhere so multiple updates to
the same key can be happening
concurrently in different places at at
the same time and they are merged by the
lattice lazily via gossip and so you
build this thing with no concurrency
control whatsoever so there's no locks
in this system there's no calls to
Atomic instructions on processors
there's certainly no paxos protocols or
anything like that it's just put get and
gossip it's really a simple piece of
software and so chenang Wu the student
who led this won the dissertation award
I think it was very welld deserved
because this system was really elegant
and really fast um so to give you a
sense of kind of the lates that he uses
he took from the literature a variety of
these kind of consistency models that
people talk about it distributed systems
and he showed how you can get them by
building little composite lates that
wrap up the data so this is what's
called last Rider wins uh in the
distributed systems which is just
whenever you see a value that's from
later than your value you update
otherwise you don't and this you just
you know take your map of which is from
keys to things and you wrap the things
in lexical pair of a clock or a version
and the data right and you can only have
one value per version so this uh this
works out as a lattice um here's a
fancier one though this is actually one
of the strongest or uh uh forms of
consistency you can get without
coordination it's called causal
consistency and here what you have is
for every key you have a vector clock
and the data and the vector clock itself
is a map lce with uh node IDs and
counters yes a little bit of sort of
operational transform kind a little bit
yes can you ever get stuck like do
repairs always exist or do you set it up
such that they do so these these
particular well trodden uh forms of
consistency work fine and these lates
are capturing that they're saying look
it's just merge all right and it's
always going to work because You'
defined an associative commutative item
poent merge function OTS are like really
weird and full of all sorts of reasoning
I don't understand um and they would
never be able to have such a simple
assertion of correctness all I'm saying
here is it's associative commu of and
item poent I got nothing more to say um
it takes a little bit of convincing to
say that gives you causal consistency
but it's not much convincing because
this is how people CLE consistency with
Vector clocks so the observation that
clocks and Vector clocks are latices is
just a nice thing about distributed
program yeah so what do you mean by
everything is a lce so you mention that
K St is a hash right key has to
be so the nice thing about um the the
map lattice is the keys are not lattice
values the keys are just Keys the whole
table is a lce but the OB the object is
a lattice because what happens is the
merge function is for a particular key
if there's nothing it gets the value you
gave or for that key if there's
something there you apply the merge
function of this
lattice and so that is itself a lattice
right and these lattice Constructors are
very nice we have map lattice you see
lexical pair over there um and these
allow you to take simple laes like sets
and counters and build up richer lates
out of them which is a trick our group
likes to play a lot other groups sort of
are doing research on inventing custom
lates for custom problems we've been
very much in this kind of let's just
Build It Up from very simple building
blocks um so the the quick version is
it's monotone and if it's monotone the
colum theorem says it's going to be uh
free replication so you don't have to do
coordination to get replica consistency
Connor is going to give you a longer
talk about this when we get to uh
conversation about semi Lattis soon it's
a semi lattice that should be clear not
a lattice it's a sem do you know there's
a people working on um uh coordination
free replicated data structures are
aware of your yes they are aware and
Connor will talk about it soon yeah yeah
yeah that will come up for sure yeah
good so um just to to kind of close out
this anecdote with Anna the system is
ridiculously fast and it's especially
ridiculously fast under contention
relative to other systems so we compared
against things like Mast tree which is
from Harvard it's Eddie Ker's very fast
key value store we also compared against
the multi-threaded uh hash table that
comes from Intel in their thread
building blocks Library that's TBB and
under contention those systems if you
look down here spend most of their time
trying and failing to get Atomic
instructions so they'll say test and set
on a particular memory address and
they'll be told no you have to try again
and they'll spend 95% of their time
under contention doing that not doing
useful work so they're at 5% good put if
you're familiar with that term um
whereas Anna because it does no
concurrency control is just doing puts
and gets and puts and gets and puts and
gets and it's spending most of its time
doing goodp put and that's why Anna can
be 700x better throughput under high
contention than these other systems it
also because it does no coordination
scales almost perfectly linearly across
threads and then across machines and
eventually across the globe um there's
really nothing to keep it from scaling
linearly because the only extra work it
has to do is some gossip and that can be
done in the background and uh can be
done as lazily as you like without
breaking the semantics um so there may
be a little fudging here on how stale
your data is but it's
correct um so this was a crazy fast
system and um the thing about this oh
and you know if you if you try to run it
in the cloud it's also incredibly cheap
to run relative to systems that are
wasting all their time doing this
business they're charging you for this
right they're trying to get locks
they're waiting on locks and they're
charging you money so you'd like to
avoid that if you can okay uh that's all
very nice but you know it was written in
C++ by Chen gang who's an excellent
coder his implementation is correct by
assertion um it would be really nice to
be able to kind of do what Cod wants us
to do formalize a spec that is correct
and then synthesize and implementation
from it through rules that are correct
Transformations right so we'd really
like to do that and we'd like to
maintain the speed what kind of
formalisms well you know we're using
lates mostly so maybe we could have a
type system that starts with some basic
semi lattices like sets and counters
some composition lses like key value
pairs products lexical products which
aren't always luses so you have to
there's some constraints on R lexical
product is L and then we want like a
data flow like a query plan algebra so
you can imagine a semi-ring kind of
algebra but you know there's going to be
maps and folds and then there's going to
be physical stuff like scan a collection
or get stuff over a network you know
networks do weird things like they
permute things and they form batches of
things they parenthesize streams if you
will um they Multiplex and demultiplex
messages so there's some physical stuff
that we want here too and I'd like to
really be able to prove all that stuff
is is correct in a meaningful way so
just for fun I don't expect you to read
this this is the Anna implement you just
saw written in our lowlevel hydroflow
language this is the whole thing it's a
very simple program um and you can see
this is kind of a data flow language
it's basically specifying graphs of data
flow the edges are directed edges in a
graph the words are nodes in the graph
and you'll see familiar operators like
map and join and uh cross join and so on
all right and you can uh give views
names so this is a little name of a
subgraph and use it and so on so it's
just a little language for specifying
graphs this is a picture of that program
that's that's output by the system okay
so it's a one one piece of paper program
are the S operations in the program um
so in this particular program there
Union is actually join it's semi latus
join um and that might be the only
one uh
yeah okay um and so just to convince
ourselves this is fast that's Chen
gang's original numbers um we have it
now running through Hydro that
implementation you saw on very similar
machines and we get very similar
performance to the handwritten code so
we're feeling pretty good that we're
hitting our goals for
performance and because this graph is
green it's telling us that this thing is
all monotone and therefore consistently
replicable um and at a glance we can see
this is a safe program and I'm sort of
cheating at this point and I'm going to
confess to that there's um I think more
work we need to do to make this robust I
think these green edges are kind of a
they're slightly bi assertion at this
point so I would like to make them more
uh fundamentally correct and hopefully
we'll have time to talk about that
later okay with that I'm gonna hand off
to Connor he gonna take us through the
next
chapter hello people hear me yes I'm
Conor I'm a PhD student here working on
hydro uh I like systems and theor so I
thought I'd show you guys some of the
theory stuff we've been thinking about
see if anyone has any thoughts wants to
collaborate on
anything uh okay so in the classical
database lens we have you know these
three layers the relational calculus at
the top uh relational algebra in the
middle and then a physical algebra at
the bottom concerned with things like uh
hashing and sorting and so on and we can
think about how this changes when we
move to the cloud
setting and there's good news and bad
news on the current state of affairs
when we move to the cloud setting the
good news is that like Joe said at the
top we have this datalist language from
the bloom project that is a data log
like dialect for distributed systems uh
the bad news is that developers are not
asking for a data log dialect to build
distributed systems in um the developers
we've talked to are a lot more
interested in a functional algebraic
looking interface and especially
something pythonic looking like
pandas um on the algebra side the good
news is that there is an algebraic model
for distributed systems today it's the
semi latus model that Jo has mentioned
that um is referred to as crdts in a lot
of places especially in the programming
languages Community um the bad news is
that this is a model for coordination
free updates of state and it doesn't
actually have a query language or give
guarantees about coordination freeness
of queries
today and then at the physical layer um
when we add a network to the situation
asynchronous computer network uh a lot
of non-determinism emerges that we need
to be able to handle particular uh
reordering batching and duplication of
messages so what we'd like to get to is
uh unifying formalism across logic and
algebra and this physical algebra um and
have correctness at the physical layer
um that we can prove we're safe against
this non determinism from the network um
and we're able to capture things like
replication partitioning um batching or
calization and termination analysis
we'll talk about more
later all right so let's talk about
semil luses
CRS um so this is a model for
distributed systems that in databases we
usually call the semul latus model what
it's called in Anna and Bloom L um it
came out of the programming language
community and there it's usually
referred to as crdts um it stands for
Conflict Free replicated data types um
is introduced in this paper here and
there's over 179 papers about CD out
there um it's also started to get
popular amongst software engineers and
you see people talk about this crdt
model on places like Hacker News people
starting startups with it so what does
it do uh it tries to handle the sources
of non-determinism that come from a
asynchronous computer network um these
are the arbitrary batching of messages
arbitrary reordering of
messages and arbitrary duplication of
messages and so it turns out if you want
to be robust to these three things these
actually correspond to algebraic
properties that you need to give you
that robustness so associativity gives
you robustness to batching you're
indifferent to the
parenthesizes commutativity gives you
robustness to reordering and item potent
gives you robustness to duplication if
you have a set with an operator that
satisfies these three properties that
gives you a semi latus so that's why
we're talking about semi luses for
distributed
systems um so the conflict free
replicated data type is one specific
model of uh semil latus interface but
since it's the most popular one today we
going to talk about it um so the idea is
that it's an objectoriented view of a
distributed system where you define some
object and you're going to Define three
methods on that object and then you can
replicate this object across the
distributed system and the replicas will
converge um regardless of network
nondeterminism so you have your merge
operator which is your associative
communative and item potent
ACI uh semul latus operator Ator which
combines the state of two replicas you
have a way to update State um which the
requirement is just that that's monotone
with respect to the partial order
induced by this merge operation and then
you have a query um which is just a
method on this object but today there's
not a specific query language you don't
have any sort of guarantees what that
query does it just reads this semil
latus
state so we look at an example of a crdt
this comes from the Amazon Dynamo paper
for how they're implement shopping
carts um and the idea is that you have
updates that are going to add or remove
elements to your shopping cart in this
case you add a Ferrari to your shopping
cart at a potato you can also remove the
Ferrari and the state is going to be
represented as two sets a set of items
that you've inserted in a set of items
that you've
removed and then to merge we do a
pairwise union of these two sets and the
query what's actually in my shopping
cart I want to check out is set
difference subtract the removes from the
inserts
um and there's a few interesting things
going on with this example one is we're
guaranteeing the coordination free um
rights that these two states are going
to
converge but our query is a non-monotone
query which the com theorem tells us is
not a coordination free query so crdts
are not giving us the invariance that
the com theorem requires on queries
which is that if we output a tuple at a
certain point in time we're never going
to retract that Tuple in the future here
uh over time we will retract tuples as
the remove set
grows we had a vision paper in BLB this
year about this gap between what crdt is
guarantee and what the comp theorem
guarantees and ideas for how to resolve
it um another thing you might have
noticed that's kind of odd about that
representation of data is that if you
think about how we might represent
updates like this to a shopping cart in
a database um you might have imagined
that we would have a count on each item
and we would increment that count when
we add an item and we decrement that
count when we remove an item this is
what you'd see something like
incremental view maintenance where your
update operation forms an a bilon group
not a semil latus so why not do
something like that um well
it's for one it doesn't form a semil
latus and it's not immediately obvious
how to convert it into one um so this
representation as two sets what you call
a two-phase set is more obviously
monotonically growing up
operation but it turns out it actually
is possible to convert this ailan group
representation into a valid semil latus
in terms of being robust to network non
determinism I won't go into all the
details on that but it's based on what
Joe is saying with these Vector clock
clocks where you wrap the uh States
basically in a vector clock which forms
a semul latus um the downside of doing
this is that Vector clocks require
linear memory in the number of replicas
in the system it's another reason why
people wouldn't use this representation
today um but we have some work on a
protocol for enforcing this kind of um
conversion into a semil latus in
constant rather than linear space so if
anyone's interested in that idea
definitely come find me and talk about
it okay so like I said the semil latus
model today does not have a query
language on top of it so what might we
want out of a query language for the
semil latus model well we want
expressivity um like we saw in the
shopping cart example we need set
difference so we need negation um also
recursion something like data
log um we also want obviously classical
query optimization options we want
identities that we can use to transform
our query get better performance uh and
we want to be able to do monotonicity
analysis as well as functional
dependency analysis for
partitioning and so some something like
uh you know data log o for semil luses
um might be a good fit here but there's
a lot to explore and so now Joe is going
to talk about this monotonicity analysis
and functional dependency
analysis all
right thanks con and I should say you
know from the previous slide that some
of this is things we we took a crack at
with Bloom l so it's not that we've done
nothing here there's there's some
answers to these questions but there's
also work to be done
all right um so I wanted to step back
and review for you folks the C theorem
which I know is sort of in a in a sub
corner of the pods community and not
everyone's going to be familiar with it
but I think it's useful to go over this
will be high level but hopefully helpful
enough for you to get into the into the
game um so the challenge is that we're
going to have uh you know computers
spread across the globe and we want our
replicas to be consistent so you know we
have this nice couple here they're in
different places and they you know the
classic example of replica consistency
is data replication so forget about
programs we're just going to have data
kind of like the crdt model and I want
everybody to have common beliefs about
the data at least eventually um so these
two folks currently both believe that X
is love which is lovely but if it's a
beautiful variable things could change
right and that's very sad and once they
disagree on the value they might make
decisions based on their disagreement
that will leave to fur lead to further
Divergence this is sometimes called the
the split brain problem because you
can't put it back together later on it's
too many
right and so we want to generalize the
idea of consistency of data replication
to consistency of program outcomes so
I'm not just interested in the data I'm
interested in the queries if you will
right um much more powerful and it will
allow us to cheat sometimes the data
could be inconsistent if the query
outcomes are not right so it'll it'll
give us more ability to relax our
coordination so we'd like to generalize
this to program outcomes independent of
data races when we can the classical
solution to this stuff is coordination
this is what things like paxos and
two-phase commit were invented to solve
and the way they Solve It Is by saying
what if we were just on one computer
with one processor maybe we could
Implement that in a distributed fashion
which is a very heavy-handed solution
right you say that our solution to
parallelism is to remove it and how can
we remove it in the distributed context
well it's expensive but here's how it
goes right um in a on a single node you
use Atomic instructions right so if you
have shared memory you can use Atomic
instructions or maybe you use a locking
system in a distributed environment you
use something like paos or two-phase
commit and at every scale as you saw in
that Ana work you'd like to not do these
things so even on a single machine you
really don't want to be doing
coordination and certainly in the
distributed setting this is very
heavyweight and there's people who will
tell you at Great length why they don't
let the developers in Amazon call these
libraries unless they have you know 16
gold stars it will slow down the whole
environment and create Q backups and all
kinds of horrible things so when can we
avoid coordination this was a question
that I asked as a lazy Professor because
I was thinking maybe I should learn and
teach paxos and I kind of didn't want to
so I was like maybe you know maybe we
don't need this stuff maybe lamport's
just a bunch of bunk um so that's kind
of where this started sheer laziness
intellectual laziness which I will C to
but what it led to sometimes when you
ask a question about how can I be lazy
you end up asking a question that turns
out to be quite interesting I think
that's what arose here and I'm seeing
this not only in my work but in other
places back in the 20th century if you
will the Lamport gray era we were trying
to emulate sequential computation we
were doing everything we could to give
the programmer the illusion of a
sequential computer and it was all about
you know very low-level stuff reads and
writs accesses in stores right and then
uh guarantees of order total order
linearizability and serializability and
this was all based on the idea that
programmers are hopeless they'll write
all kinds of crazy code and the only
thing they understand is sequential
computers so we'll make the worst case
assumption that their stuff wouldn't
work in parallel right and we'll give
mechanisms for avoiding parallelism
seems like a terrible thing to do in a
parallel environment yeah so what's
happening in the 21st century is if we
lift our so this is all great and
sometimes you need it I don't mean to
denigrate the work there's obviously
foundational touring Awards I use this
stuff I teach this stuff it's all good
but when we don't need to use it even
better right so people have tried doing
things like what if all our states
immutable that's a very functional
programming game um sort of in my world
it's more about well you can mutate
things as long as it's monotone so
they're mutable but they're monotone
maybe that'll work um and then using
things like dependencies and provenance
all are ways of using application
knowledge to avoid using the expensive
stuff on the left but the really big
query is when do I need coordination and
why do I need coordination so if you ask
you know a typical undergraduate or
frankly most people in computer science
including professors when do you need
coordination what's a lock for right
they'll say well it's to avoid conflicts
on shared resources right this
intersection needs coordination if you
would just put up some damn stop lights
right then you know north south could go
for a while and west east west would
wait and then East West would go for a
while north south would wait problem
solved all right but like do I really
need coordination that's a solution is
it the only solution no it's not the
only solution right here's a
coordination free solution to that
intersection problem right so I'd like
to be able to think out of the box right
and say really what is coordination for
when am I required to use
[Music]
it okay um so that's a theory problem so
you know which programs have a
coordination free implementation call
those the green programs these are
specifications for which a clever
programmer can find a coordination free
solution and then of course there's the
rest of the
programs right and I want to know this
green line will someone please tell me
you know Mr Lamport I think I only need
you out here so will you please tell me
when I need you and there's no answer
from Mr Lamport at least he didn't you
know pick up the phone when I called um
but uh I'm happy to say the people at
hustel did and this is what led to the
column theorem so this is really
computability question what's the
expressive power of languages without
coordination yeah that's the green
circle okay so give you some intuition
um easy and hard questions here's an
easy question is anyone in the room over
18 excellent not only were you all happy
to answer that coordination free but you
in a little protocol right you made up a
protocol where you raise a hand if you
think it's true so that was cool so that
was the monotone hand raising protocol
something great all right who's the
youngest person in the
room me oh we have some Brave some brave
assertions but clearly you don't know
that um you could you could look at
everyone but that's cheating and also
not necessarily
right maybe maybe I don't know I don't
know um but the point here is right uh
that somehow this requires you to
communicate with people and the first
one maybe doesn't Okay more to the point
let's look at the logic here right this
is an existential question and this is a
question with a universal quantifier in
it or you know for people like me who uh
just want to do total pattern matching
and look for not symbols that one
appears to be positive so I'll say that
it's monotone and that one appears to be
negative so I'll say it's non monotone
so it gives you some intuition that
Universal quantification or negation
requires coordination it is coordination
that's what coordination is it's
Universal quantification so you know
what is Lamport for it's for Universal
quantifiers so let's just prove this
right I was like well somebody prove it
I'm not going to prove it so uh uh nice
guy named Tom amalo wrote a thesis on
this stuff um my conjecture was called
the calm conjecture consistency as
logical monotonicity it was in a pods
keynote that I was uh give some years
ago and then just a year later there was
a conference paper from the good Folks
at hosel which then they uh extended and
then was further extended with with
weaker definitions for the monotonicity
to really expand the results if you want
a quick you know kind of a version of
what I'm saying now you can read this
kakum overview but it's really for
systems people I think you guys should
just read Tom's
papers all right to give you a flavor of
what Tom did definitions are half the
battle it seems you know when I read
pods papers that's all the hard parts
are the definitions right um so you know
what monotonicity is in logic that's
fine uh what is consistency here well we
want the program to produce the same
output regardless of where the initial
data is placed so I should be able to
start the program with the data
replicated pop possibly and partitioned
in any way and get the same answer and
if that's true then it would be the same
answer across replicas it would be the
same answer across different runs it
would be the same answer if we start
gossiping the data between each other um
and this is what we want right so that's
our definition of consistency where I
think what's really clever and was the
most beautiful part of the work is
defining what coordination really means
so we're sending messages around right
that's data but which data is really
data and which data is kind of control
messages how you differentiate those in
a formal way and so what uh they defined
in this paper is a program is
coordination free if there's some
partitioning of the data when you first
start so there's some layout of the data
where you first start such that the
query can be answered without
communication so for a particular query
for a particular data set there is some
world of where you lay it out where no
communication is
required okay that's the definition of
coordination freeness and a program that
you can't do that on is doing
coordination messages
okay so it's not really saying which
messages are coordination and which
messages are data but it's telling you
which programs can be run
coordination just put Alla on one yes so
the trivial example of this is you put
all the data on one node and again you
know this question of is there anybody
who is uh older than me if what you
don't know is whether anyone else has
data so I may have all the data but I
don't know that so I still have to ask
everybody anybody got any data and I
have to wait for everybody to respond
right so it's very nice intuition to
just think about having all the data on
one
great all right there's another thing in
the paper that I hadn't even anticipated
which is really beautiful and speaks to
stuff that the distributed systems
Community kind of knows um which is
there's a third equivalent which is that
you can distributively compute this
program on an oblivious transducer and I
haven't even talked about transducers
yet but just a minute but what does he
mean by oblivious it means that the
agent in the system doesn't know its own
identity it cannot distinguish messages
from
itself from messages from anyone else so
it doesn't actually know who itself is
and it doesn't know the set of
participants we call this an oblivious
agent all right oblivious programs that
can be computed by oblivious agents are
exactly the monotone programs and
exactly the coordination free programs
so that was very cool and it speaks to
questions of like membership protocols
in distributed systems which is about
establishing common knowledge of the all
relation that's it's like one of the
things that paxos does is it has a
membership protocol built in so it's one
of the reasons it's coordination full is
to establish all so this was really
really nice so this is all in this jcm
paper uh it's actually in the conference
the pods paper as well that's just a
flavor of the Calm stuff and I'm gonna
stop with that but happy to answer
questions as best I can afterwards and
with that I'm gonna give it back to
Connor you guys can still hear
me um all right so we have this calm
theorem view of the world relational
transducers logic um operating over sets
and then we have the semil latus algebra
view of the world um and they both are
dealing with coordination freeness in
different lenses but currently they
guarantee different things uh the
algebra view like we said is concerned
with the coordination freeness of Rights
and does not guarantee coordination
freeness of qu queries whereas the
column theorem view is only concerned
with the coordination freeness of
queries it actually doesn't have to
worry about the coordination freeness of
Rights because it assumes your operating
over sets and gets coordination of
Rights for free that
way um and so we're interested in the
question of how can we combine these two
lenses can we do an algebraic view of
the Colm theorem um and some intuition
for how that might work is you know the
semil latus operator induces a partial
order
um and so instead of having monotone
logical queries without negation you
have monotone functions between lates
between partial orders um so that's
something we've been exploring we' love
to chat more about it with folks uh I'm
actually going to talk about a
problem specific to the question Remy
asked it's a comes up in this setting so
the colum theorum is all about basically
not knowing when you have the entire
input what can I output and um tell
Downstream consumers with certainty even
though I might have more updates in the
future there might be more messages
arriving and so we call the ability to
do this free
termination
[Music]
um without coordination what can we be
sure that we can output and we're
exploring this in a very generic setting
of just we have two functions an update
operation that's going to change our
state over time and a query um that's
going to return some
output
so looking at an example of when we
might be able to do this we can look at
this lattice this is the set over these
four
socks um and say that this is our state
of a local node and we're at top in this
lattice and our update um operation in
the crdt sense is uh Union so we're
going to Union in more socks we know
that if we're at top this update as
monotone uh we'll never change our state
we're stuck at top and so whatever query
we might be asking when we're in this
state we'd be able to locally detect
that our query result is not going to
change in the future and we'd be able to
return our result with
certainty this might sound like it would
not happen particularly often but let's
try and look at more examples where we
would be able to figure out that with
certainty we can return uh an answer
right
now so what if we consider also the
query that we're asking and say that
this query is going to map us from uh
this set socks lattice to the Boolean
lattice true false where top is
true now um if this query is monotone
meaning as we go up in the partial order
of socks we also go up in the partial
order of false and true then uh we don't
need to be at top on the left uh we can
actually be at top in the true false
lattice and guarantee that our result
won't change as future updates arrive
any update that arrives is gonna it'll
cause us to increase monotonically in
the domain which has to increases
monotonically in the range and therefore
our result will always stay
true uh for example a query is there a
pair of
socks what we call a threshold query it
effectively draws a cut through this
partial order and says everything above
this line in the partial order is true
Everything below this line is
false so these Boolean threshold queries
are a class of queries that we can
freely terminate on if we know that
update is
monotone
um what about a totally different
setting what if we throw away
monotonicity so now imagine that we have
a deterministic finite aoma and our
query is you know mapping to true and
false from you know accept and reject
states in the automa and our update is
appending a character so we think of a
streaming um characters appending the
satoma so each update is going to
transition us one step in the satoma
um and in this automa any state that
we're in uh we can't conclude what the
final result will be because from every
state there's a state that's accepting
that's reachable and there's a state
that's rejecting that's reachable so
some sequence of future updates might
take us to false some sequence of future
updates might take us to
true in contrast if state three were
also true now from State one we actually
don't know if we're going to end up
accept or rejecting uh if we don't have
the whole input yet but if we're in
States two or three we know that every
state that's reachable via future
updates is going to keep us in our
current uh result which is true and so
we can be certain that we can terminate
here and return true so this is kind of
like a reachability sort of visual view
of how we're thinking about whether or
not you can freely terminate given some
arbitrary update operation on a domain
and query operation that Maps you to
arrange um this is a question interested
in exploring a lot of different domain
so if anyone has any ideas for what
might connect to this definitely come
find
us now Joe is going to talk about
partitioning this is a bit of a
survey did you want to ask a Qui
question a quick question to the last
slide right because in the sense is now
still has a monotone ordering right this
kind of like yeah okay in a sense it's
kind of like if I can reach a note and
it's uh smaller and now basically the
notes if the terminal noes are the top
noes in right they don't have larger
nodes and then so it's still monotone in
the sense yeah you could find some sort
of it that yeah yeah I don't know if
that's true all for every really
terminating function psych
detction yeah
maybe um there's something about
quotient laes to going
at in partial ERS but the graph of SP
component
so this is I would love to have this
conversation afterwards that's why we're
touching on a few things so we can have
many conversations so um I think given
time I'm not going to go through this in
any detail I'm GNA basically skip this
chapter of the talk except to quickly uh
give some assertions so first of all we
don't have hydroflow so we use deists um
and we do have a full deadalus to
hydroflow compiler so we're able to
write Global programs in deist and then
Auto partition and auto replicate them
and that's work being led by David Chu
who's in the room over here
um David three years ago promised to do
this and they gave him a certificate
saying that's cool um so he won the SSP
student research award and three years
later so he's got his first results so
it took a while this was not an easy
problem but he's able to um take
arbitrary dead deadlist programs which
are datalog and um partition uh them to
run on multiple machines and I'm really
not going to spend a lot of time on this
what I'll say is that I had a earlier
student Michael Whitaker who again did
this by assertion he found all sorts of
opportunities to optimize paxos because
inside of paxos it was bottlenecking on
things that were trivially
parallelizable like Network message
handling so he's like if I can just bust
apart some of the roles in paxos into
subroles some of those sub rolls can be
replicated and he got state-of-the-art
performance in terms of throughput on
paxos by doing this um and what I
observed after he did it was oh my gosh
most of the things that you've split out
are monotone subcomponents and I should
have known that could pull those out and
replicate those in fact I wish Bloom
could do that automatically but it
couldn't so three years later David can
now automatically pull out these things
that Michael was observing and uh
transformed the program uh to to do it
and the ideas are
basically just two tricks one trick is
to take a pipeline on a single machine
and split it across two machines he
calls that decoupling now in a general
purpose program this is taking I don't
know 10,000 lines of C++ and figuring
out which ones to run in this machine
and which ones to run in that machine
that would be horrible right but in a
data flow language or a logic language
it's quite nice and so he has conditions
for when this is safe and when it's not
so that's decoupling so you can think of
this as refactoring a program into
components that can be run on different
machines with asynchronous communication
the other thing he does is what's
sometimes called sharding in the
practitioner Community but it's
partitioning shared nothing partitioning
of sub plants right so instead of having
BC take all of the data from a you have
a hash partitioning here and certain
values go to each machine and how do you
know that each one of these computations
can be done independently that's done
through things like um functional
dependency analysis so that you can show
that certain values uh have no
dependency on other values because
they're practition by say FD so I'm not
going to go into any of this but
basically what David was able to do was
take many of the optimizations here that
were handwritten in Scala and automate
them and formalize their correctness and
without getting into too much detail
although it is kind of fun
oh and we borrowed some work from Paris
so shout out to Paris uh for um parallel
disjoint
correctness and
col um it is really fast so um he was
able automatically this is Michael's
results that we ran this is his Scala
this is throughput against latency so
what you want to do is you get as much
throughput as you can until it starts to
hurt you on latency and it curls back
okay so this is kind of where things
start
to top out if you will so that's
Whitaker's implementation this is the
same logic as Whitaker's implementation
in Hydro so this is just Hydro is faster
than schola written by hand so this is
just a testament to the folks who wrote
the hydroflow engine um but the blue
line is what David achieved through
systematic correctly proven rewrites so
he was able to get performance that
actually because Hydro is fast is is
better than waur paxos implementation
and this Gap is kind of what he's given
up these are the tricks that Michael had
that we didn't cover in our Ras
okay but we're doing
90% with the easy
tricks so it gives me confidence that
simple query optimizations known in
parallel databases can have impacts on
places that were really very fine-tuned
performance issues that people rate phds
to get this kind of performance and
we're getting it through systematic
reates very promising um David's only
halfway there though because he has to
have a proper cost based Optimizer right
now what he has is correct
transformation rules he needs a cost
model with an objective function
um and then he needs a search strategy
and we're hopefully going to be using uh
egg egg log or some implementation of
egg log in hydroflow um to achieve this
so we're one of the things with Max's
stuff that overlaps is if there's a
lovely semi latus based data flow
implementation of uh of Max's stuff
maybe we can clean up some of the things
where he's doing updates in place
language is the target of that work this
work this work well so this was written
in datalog and translated down into that
Hydro flow data flow language you saw up
the top um this stuff is also written in
data log currently in a runtime that
plays some ad hoc tricks so it's not
traditional data log execution here as
Max Wasing to yeah but I think you know
uh Union find is a nice Target for an
algebraic treatment I think I think we
have
opportunity okay what I'd like to do in
the last few minutes is berate you with
questions um because these are the
things that I don't know how to answer
yet and I would love to get help with so
the first is and this is an outline so
this section goes on for many slides but
there's the four questions can we please
have one theory for all this nonsense
instead of um the list I'm about to show
you um what would be a good type system
for the physical layer where we could
prove correctness of
Transformations I have a follow on to
sudipa about the role of of uh our kinds
of work in the era of generative Ai and
then um I have this ongoing question of
what time is for which I probably don't
have time to
explain but quickly you know the
unifying Theory thing so crdts are
semilattices data log datalist was all
done with model Theory and it's fancy
actually it uses like uh stable models
and stuff it's it's it's actually ended
up being kind of fancy the CM theorem
amute proofs have these relational
transducers which are this halfway World
between operational and declarative
semantics you have these State machines
on each node they run declarative
languages on each step but then they
output stuff
and
uh I think you can write non-
terminating programs if you want to um
so you can write toggle for example in
De
and I mean the transducers yeah the
transducers need they each no they don't
have to be terminated in any sense I
don't think um but the point is I really
wish he' had done this work with this
because he also was on this work but he
didn't he did it with transducers which
is a bummer um if you talk to
distributed systems people they talk
about essentially order Theory they talk
about partial orders all the time time
which is related to Lates but you know
it's annoying um programmers want to
write these sort of algebraic functional
Expressions which I think is a good
thing for all of us all right and then
yeah you know I give all these talks and
then somebody some Joker raises their
hand and says but what about
transactions um and in fact Peter bis
when he was a student basically did an
end run around my entire group and just
wrote papers about transactions and and
uh coordination freeness and they don't
align with the rest of the stuff so it's
open challenge to reintegrate that work
and then you know I didn't say the s
word yet because I apparently didn't do
joins as of yet but we do do joins so we
probably need right so it would be
really great to get all of it here I
would like to bring all of this work
into this domain that would be really
nice okay um here's a flavor of what I'm
dealing with though um so um just
finished reading the dbsp paper which
was very nice and related to our work
but we have some other things we need to
keep track of that are relating to the
Network messing with stuff so when we
look at a stream it's got some values
it's got some happen stance ordering
that's a mapping of the naturals to
those values it's got some happen stance
batching it came in over the network in
chunks so there's like singly nested
parentheses in this stream that are
randomly placed randomly you know
arbitrarily ordered arbitrarily placed
maybe this is a stream of latus points
but maybe it's not I don't know but if
it is you could say things like there's
a monotonicity relationship between the
type's natural order and the total order
of arrival or not right then what sort
does is it enforces something like this
right uh it's nice when these are
atomistic like data flow is basically a
set lattice that you flow individual
atoms that's the traditional kind of
database iterator thing one tupal at a
time right one tupal at a time is an
atomistic lattice of the sets of tupal
um and it's nice when you know you're
dealing with atoms because you can say
things like item potents right I I gave
you Bob's tupal once I gave you Bob's
tupal twice sorry but you should only
have it once so delete one but if I give
you subsets now you have to find how
they overlap and you have to make sure
that when you Union them you remove the
overlapping bits and so when you have
non- atomistic things it's just a little
uglier and you end up talking about like
does there meat is there meat bot kinds
of things do they have no intersection
right so these are kinds of properties
that I think I need to track in my
rewrite rules and then you know the
operators are they invariance to these
properties like lattice's lattice
operations are invariant to order and
parenthesize
do they preserve the properties do they
enforce different values for the
properties the network
non-deterministically enforces orders
and parenthesizes so like this is the
stuff that I worry about in my operators
um and this is kind of the soup I'm
swimming in with this uh physical
algebra so I would like help with this
all right I'm GNA do one more quick
slide um this is very much in the realm
of what sudipo was talking about you
know we're in the era where people will
be programming with green goo right it's
just uh uh this is large language models
they're magical they produce stuff but
what we really want is building blocks
that we can count on right we're
database people our industry is all
about foundational building blocks and I
really do think declarative
specification is a lovely narrow waste
here between these two where we can take
a formal spec as Cod asked us to we can
render it in some sense so that it's
readable right and this relates to
things like Wulf gong's work on
visualizing queries and what sudipo was
talking about in terms of giving natural
language things but helping people look
at this and say is this what you meant
you not is it correct but is this what
you meant it's a spec after all right
did you mean this query um and then of
course if it's in a nice formal language
we can check it for other things right
um and so that would be uh I think a
role that we can really play in the
world and I I suspect things like this
will happen it's just these programs are
G to be a selection of programs you're
constantly going to be given a menu of
which of these things did you mean and
the answer to which is either some
invariant checks or something or some
human judgment so I think we in a good
spot in terms of intermediate languages
and I'll just close with one more slide
um maybe just a handful of slides what
are clocks in time for and distributed
systems so there's this famous saying
which is correctly attributed to a
Sci-Fi uh short story time is what keeps
everything from happening all at once so
when should we use time and Computing
what what are clocks for well they're
not for monotone queries I can run this
embarrassingly parallel it can all
happen at the same time and it's fine
and Balo was doing this long before uh
this
discussion but I can't run this at the
same time right you can't have p and not
P at the same time so what's the deadest
answer to that is well that's what time
is for this is the toggle
program right and time is there to
separate two things that can't
coexist that should be I think the only
reason for
time okay except it's not um distributed
systems people use time for maintaining
partial Ord and knowing when things were
concurrent sometimes you don't need that
sometimes you do but this is my question
especially because Val's in the room and
worked on his DSP stuff deist has one
clock per node and we update it only
when there's a network event or we have
to cycle through um
negation timely and differential data
flow have clocks all over the damn place
and I'm not sure when you use them and
when you don't um so for example
tracking iterations of a monotonic
recursive program why do I need a clock
for that I don't think I need a clock
for that maybe if it's a while and we
use the index in our computation I need
to know what index I'm at so the general
question is when do we use this
structure called a
clock and when don't we need and can a
compiler decide all right we're a little
over time I hope we have given you lots
of things to ask us later um and we need
lots of help so we'd love it and we are
big fans of working with folks like you
can you leave these last four slides
there so we can come
[Music]
[Applause]
ch